some of the worst violence is happening
in the city of Janina more than 300
people are reported to have been killed
there in recent days
Aid agencies are warning of catastrophic
conditions for civilians
meanwhile the Sudanese Army says it's
pushed back in advance by the rapid
support forces in onderman and says
equipment including heavy arms has been
destroyed but north of Khartoum the
rapid support forces says it has gained
control of several military bases the
group has released pictures that it says
shows the capture of 700 Sudanese
soldiers
more than 800 people have died in the
fighting which is now in its second
month well let's bring in Heber Morgan
she joins us live now from onderman here
but both sides seem to be claiming
victories in areas fairly close to each
other who actually has the upper hand at
the moment
well it depends on the facilities and
the areas in the capital Khartoum where
the rsf is present and where the
Sudanese Army is present right now the
Sudanese Army is still in control of the
general command of the Army Headquarters
that's been the scene of intense
fighting between the two sides at the
start of this uh our struggle more than
a month ago the rapid support forces
still control the presidential Palace
which the Sudanese Army doesn't look to
be focusing on regaining control of
right now they've been trying to Target
rsf positions in the Northern parts of
the capital in the city of Bahrain now
the Army also says that the rsf tried to
Target the military uh air base in um
duruman in the northern part of the
capital of durman that's where the
fighter jets have been taking off from
since the start of the conflict
targeting rsf positions so both sides
are trying to gain control over the
other in the capital Khartoum but
fighting has also been going elsewhere
around the country in West Starfall for
example it's been continuing for five
days now these are not the rsf but rsf
Allied militias have been targeting
residents of the city people who spoke
to this morning said that they were able
to hear Heavy Artillery that they cannot
bury their debt because of continuous
fighting and that the situation is
becoming catastrophic for them but they
have no way to flee because of the
ongoing artillery fire as well as
because of the insecurity then you have
alobade in North Korea fan people in
that area also reported Heavy Artillery
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese army they said the Army is in
control of a lubeid which is the capital
of North Korea but that the rsf is
surrounding the city from various sides
so they're worried that there will be an
escalation there both sides again
continuing to fight not only in the
capital Khartoum but in other parts of
the country trying to gain the upper
hand over the other
yeah but it's now been what over a month
since this all kicked off and there's
clearly no end in sight from what you've
just said you're across the river there
from Khartoum how is everyone holding up
well people are exhausted it's been more
than a month and the Army initially said
that this would not take more than a
week many of them had not fled but those
were remaining behind right now are not
staying because they want to but because
they have no option of leaving they
don't have relatives on outside States
they don't have the financial
capabilities to be able to support
themselves or to even leave the capital
uh those who are trapped here say that
there's a shortage of Food Supplies they
cannot get enough food to feed their
families or enough money to buy the
supplies where they are available
there's also the issue of fuel shortages
as well as Medical Services hospitals
say that they've been burdened because
of the number of Civilian injuries and
casualties that have been resulting from
the ongoing fighting uh between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army now nearly a million people have
fled from Sudan overall including from
the western region of Darfur more than
700 000 from the capital Khartoum but
those remaining behind say that the
situation is catastrophic they're
staying behind either because they don't
have the means to travel due to lack of
financial capabilities or because they
want to guard their homes from lootings
and robberies many of them risking their
lives saying that they're waiting to see
how the talks which is ongoing and Jetta
play out if there's a ceasefire they'll
try to either find their way out or take
their belongings or stay until there's a
permanent ceasefire and then enter the
conflict
huge amount at stake for so many hibber
Morgan there on the ground for us in
omderman thank you so much